hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was suggested to me a
few hours ago via email
uh by uh mikhail axelly so thank you for
that it's a game from the 33rd edition
of the stockholm
uh real-time cup uh and it's okay it's
from 2003 but it stretches out to 2004
it's probably a new year's tournament
there are quite a few tournaments that
do this uh and it's a game between uh
the
legend himself sweatshirt uh and uh
finnish
grandmaster tomi neibuck uh we've
already uh seen a game by neibuck a few
weeks ago i think the the game against
magnus carlsen if you haven't seen that
do check it out it will be the first
thing in the description below
so maybe as a warm up for this video uh
but uh gligorichi needs no introduction
basically but as i know a lot of you are
coming into the chess world
uh on a daily basis there he's
he truly is a legend there is no grand
master that he didn't
defeat like uh from bobby fischer tigran
petrossian
i don't know i don't know if he defeated
braunschweig and he defeated paul carris
he defeated night or
uh interestingly he never defeated boris
posky he faced sposky
some 22 times in uh in serious
games but he never defeated him he drew
against him quite a lot but never never
got a victory against spassky
but either way he's an extremely strong
player and uh
this was some four years uh prior to
gligorich's death
uh it was like i said in 2008 and he
still uh
played tournaments very actively uh so
without further ado let's check it out
as this is this is a very interesting
game
uh so gligorich with the white pieces
opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by nine bucks c4
and now c5 striking in the center right
away going for the benoni
defense uh we have d5 igligori grabs
more space in the center and now
b5 this is the bengal gambit or the
bangkok volga gambit
and um it's uh
well it's a very very sharp sharp
opening for black where black
offers some material for for very rapid
development so c
captures mb5 uh we have a6 and
b captures on a6 uh so the the benco has
been fully accepted with uh
g6 now by black preparing to vinca to
the dark square bishop
knight to c3 and now bishop captures an
a6 which kind of prevents white from
playing e4
uh because then black will just capture
and white loses castling privileges but
this is exactly what white does
and this is uh the the absolute the best
way to counter
black's plans here so e4 you really
don't mind
you're gonna play king to f1 then in the
future king to g1 and so on
so basically you're going to castle
artificially so bishop captures on f1
was played
king captures and d6 now and this is
nothing new this has all been played
before many times
uh and here nowadays uh the the top
moves here are some like
knight to f3 and also g3 is very popular
but
ligo rich decided to play bush knights
to e2 here
we have bishop to g7 and now h3 taking
away the g4 square
from black's pieces and now we have
castles by an eibach we have king to g1
and the king is coming to h2 and then
you're going to shift the rook into the
game this way
and uh therefore you will uh
artificially castle so knight b37
and now king h2 by gligorich we have
queen to a5 bringing the queen into the
game
and this is kind of the idea black
sacrificed upon for rapid development
white
does already have a past a pawn but uh
black controls the
board really the bishop cuts the board
completely in half you're going to get
this rook to b8 you're going to control
the b
file the a file the queen will help out
with
putting more pressure in the position
this knight can come to e5 this
knight can come to h5 maybe to f4 in the
future maybe to g3 even
so uh there are a lot of possibilities
here for black and white has to be very
careful as uh well a lot of games
throughout history have
shown uh when black goes for the bangkok
gambit so here
queen to c2 gligorich uh continues
development develops the queen
now uh the next is gonna develop the
bishop and then connect to the rooks of
course with rook f the b8
and now rook to d1 so nicely developing
uh and now comes
rook to b4 there are some moves that
have been played here after this game
but
rook to b4 uh was never uh well
rather it was as of move 14 that this
move has never been repeated again so we
are in completely new territory now
uh and we have rook to b1 and now uh
you have to figure out how you want to
go about this probably b3 and
a4 because you want to get rid of all of
your
weaknesses and you want to create a pass
pawn that can be
successfully pushed forward and you have
to be a little bit careful here
for example rook eight to b8 here this
is what was played by night buck and now
if lego just try something like a3 which
kind of does make sense after b3 rook b3
there's really not
all that much for white to do here and
you really you're really going to
struggle
with any ideas on how to develop your uh
your pieces
and it's going to be well it's going to
be very easy for black to play this
uh so instead after rook 8 to b8 we have
bishop to d2
and now as okay the bishop is aligned
with the rook and the queen eibach of
course moves the queen
and there are no good discoveries with
the knight so you don't have to worry
about that for the moment so he just
uh gligorish strengthens the center here
we have f3
adding more protection to the e4 pawn
and now knight to e5
with b3 as planned at some point a4 is
coming
and now rook the c8 so here nyback is
saying okay
you really covered everything there's
really not all that much i can do
all of the squares are covered like i
don't have any night night
ideas because the bishop and knight are
covering f4 the g3 is covered by the
knight in the king so
there is not a lot i can do but i can
push c4 and
open up some lines for my rooks uh and
here gligori should
uh try something like bishop to e3 and
it's very interesting that ligo rich
abandons uh this
uh this diagonal here he plays bishop to
e1 and nyback immediately takes
advantage of that he plays
knight to h5 okay now the now the f4
square has been weakened somewhat
uh but uh it's also just a ju just a
very strong piece there as you'll see uh
in the rest of the game
and now gligori should most definitely
play f4 with f4 you're saying okay
get rid of this knight and then i'm
going to just enjoy my position for
example knight moose and then we're
going to
bring the rook back to c1 uh try and put
up uh
some sort of a blockade on the on the c
file and everything here is nicely
protected you don't really have to worry
about anything on the queen side
however here gligorich rushed it a bit
too much he played
a4 and now there's a problem now uh
black has a lot of control play and
nyback uses it by playing c4
so okay b captures on c4 we have rook b
captures on c4
nothing spectacular happening here but
the rooks are doubled and the c file
your queen is on c2 so you kind of want
to move it but
uh you have to be very careful here uh
gligorich played a
queen to b3 but this simply will not do
uh queen to b3 although uh seems like a
very natural move you move the queen
away from the c
file and you know ideas like queen to b5
come to mind if black captures you're
going to get a nice pass pawn here so
everything kind of makes sense
uh the problem is it loses by force and
this is uh well
that's a big problem for uh for ligo
this year so uh feel free to pause the
video
and win this game for naiba while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
finding this uh outrageous idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's actually rook captain c3 so
congratulations to everyone who found it
it's not all that clear i mean a lot of
you probably thought of this move and
then
thought yeah but what next uh well uh to
figure that out we have to go
a little bit deeper the problem is that
bishop captures on c3
is no good because then we just play
knight captures
on f3 with check we open up a double
attack here on the bishop but that's not
even the worst thing after g
captures on f3 the knight hangs with
check so queen captures an e2 comes with
check and after king g1 now anything
really wins here for black we can just
calmly capture here
bishop d4 check is in the air at some
point if the rook moves
uh the knight can come easily to f4 we
can check mate the king this way
or if queen to b5 offering a queen trade
because there aren't all that many good
squares here like this bishop is
uh cutting off all counter play from
white there's no way for
the rooks to help out with the defense
and if something like this
offering a queen trade then we're just
going to play bishop d for check
and there is really not all that much uh
uh
you can do here uh so if you move if you
move the king let's say king h1 knights
the g3 is checkmate
and now of course if you capture the
bishop which is the other thing
then queen the e3 check king moves and
then the knight just comes
help to help out with the attack king
goes here rook to c2 with
check and that's it whatever you do
that's it king captures here
queen to g5 will be checkmated the rook
is covering the second
rank and that's it the king has nowhere
to go so uh
this seems very complicated but naibak
worked it all out and the gligorich of
course did not capture with the bishop
uh gligorich did the only other thing he
could well okay you could play queen b5
and just claim okay i don't uh
it's like i sacrificed a piece and i'm
gonna play for this past pawn
but it's it's a very it's a very slow
and painful death torture basically
so instead of what uh galigorich did
after this uh
this idea of rook captures on b3 is he
played knight captures on c3
uh but now now comes uh the other idea
and that of course is
uh well i'm sure you can see it there's
no knight here on e2 so you have to
be mindful of that but just in case you
know feel free to pause the video once
again and to win this game for nyback
well i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that it's
the exact same idea even without the
knight on e2
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's a knight
captures an f3 with check that's the
good stuff and even though the knight is
not an e2 you don't have access to e2
none of this matters because this is
just a game because if the king moves
then queen to f1 is checkmate the
knights are covering all of the
important squares here
uh so you have to capture it uh g
captures on f3 was played
but now nightmark nyback just played the
queen to f1
and it was in this position on move 24
that the sweaters are gligorich resigned
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so truly truly an amazing game i'm sure
glee rich was very impressed
with this game himself as he uh for as
he does come from the golden age of
chess would appreciate a miniature like
this
more more than you know a modern player
would i imagine
and here we resign because there is
nothing you can do
and it's just amazing bishop to e5 check
the most obvious threat
and to prevent this you kind of have to
play bishop to g3
but it just all falls apart queen
captures on f3 because now the queen is
under attack as well but you're just
gonna capture this
put pressure on the bishop here and now
again not not much can be done here if
rook to g1 defending
you're just going to play knight
captures rook captures and bishop to e5
again not much point in doing this rook
to g1
and then just rook captures in c3 with
unstoppable pressure here
there's there's no playing this uh you
could however instead of
um maybe going going for this
rook captures on g3 recapture you could
play knight to b5
and offer a trade of queens but then
just rook the c3
amazing move if queen captures then
bishop captures queen so you'd have to
capture back with the knight
and then we of course go into this
amazing checkmating pattern
knight to f1 check uh you don't really
have an option here you have to capture
the knight with either rook so rook
captures and now
bishop to e5 check only move rook g3 now
we're gonna capture it king h1 and the
queen queen to h2 will be checkmate so
after queen f1 and gligorich resigned he
calculated all of this and said that
there is no point in continuing this uh
and
this amazing amazing game was played by
tommy neibach who takes down
uh the legend uh svetozer gligorich
so really really an awesome game now
like i said if you haven't seen
the game we've covered i think a few
weeks ago where uh naibak faced magnus
carlsen uh it will be the first link in
the description below so do check it out
as well he has a very very uh
distinctive
uh style and i really really really
enjoy it
so hopefully we can dig up some more uh
crazy games like this one uh by by the
uh man himself tommy nibak uh so yeah
uh once again hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank a gentleman uh who
says uh
my daughters katherine and leela are
awesome uh best time chess
robert henderson bondcloudchest.com and
ian mantal for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day